hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a science fiction action film
called The Discovery spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie we see
Professor Thomas Harbor being
interviewed he has recently proven the
existence of life after death the
interviewer claims that his Discovery
was dangerous because ever since his
work was published the suicide rate has
been skyrocketing he dismisses the claim
by saying that such a crucial truth
about human life had to be brought to
the people regardless of the
consequences Thomas has been able to
capture brain wavelengths on a subatomic
level leaving a person's body when they
die this explains that a person's
Consciousness goes somewhere when they
die but the interviewer insists that
since they do not know where
Consciousness goes they cannot tell for
sure if the afterlife exists Thomas
tackles the claim saying that when a
train leaves the station we know it is
going somewhere she then brings up that
many celebrities athletes and hundreds
of civilians have ended their lives
because of the professor and asks him if
he feels responsible for their deaths
Thomas simply answers that he doesn't
just then one of the camera crew stands
before Thomas and thanks him for the
Fresh Start he shoots himself dead right
after in a similar fashion people have
been committing mass suicide to restart
a new life in the afterlife it is now
the second anniversary of the discovery
Thomas's son will Harbor is traveling on
a ferry listening to a TV program
talking about his father's Discovery as
it turns out the suicide rate has not
decreased ever since Will turns the TV
off making it clear that he is not proud
of his father's work a girl from the
other seat startles him they are the
only ones on the ferry she introduces
herself as Isla and will comments that
her face looks familiar the two chit
chat for a while the conversation turns
to them talking about the discovery Isla
is a supporter of it but will exclaims
that he doesn't believe in it Isla
claims that the discovery gives people a
way to get relief from the sufferings in
life but will stays adamant about his
view after they get off the ferry Isla
hitchhikes in a car leaving will at the
harbor his brother Toby comes to pick
him
the two drive to a huge mansion bought
by their father Thomas has built his new
station in the mansion and has employed
people who survived attempted suicides
will is confused to see labs and
Machinery inside the house Thomas has
been conducting some kind of experiment
will meets his father and bluntly asks
him to stop all of this he wants Thomas
to tell the media that his Discovery was
false and stopped the chain of mass
suicides Thomas laughs at his idea and
claims that his Discovery was a hundred
percent true and he won't lie to anyone
as it turns out will was the inspiration
for the discovery when will was young he
had an accident and died for a minute
when he was resuscitated he had told his
parents that he saw flashes and a little
boy in front of him this provided Thomas
with the idea that life after death
might exist hence will blames himself
for the deaths and wants his father to
stop after the conversation will goes
outside to cool his mind but just then
he sees Isla on the beach nearby she
seems to be packing her bags with
weights Isla wears the heavy bag and
goes into the sea will realizes she is
about to commit suicide and runs to save
her he goes into the water and manages
to save her but Isla is furious he takes
her to the mansion and asks Toby to take
her in since they help people who are
suicidal Toby agrees but she will have
to go through the questionnaire first
Isla is surprised to discover Thomas is
Will's father Thomas then conducts an
interview with Isla asking her questions
about her life meanwhile will goes
around the house and sees that it has
been fully converted into an
establishment with canteens and rooms
for every patient at night everyone
gathers in a room while Thomas presents
something to them he brings out a man
with a device attached to his head and
claims he has figured out a way to see
the afterlife till now the world only
knew that our brain waves leave for
somewhere after we die but now he has
figured out a way to see where the
brainwavelengths go will and the others
are shocked Thomas explains that with
the device they can see a video
recording of the afterlife later
everyone is at Thomas's office he wants
to be the first one to be experimented
upon but he has to be dead for that
hence they decide to perform it on an
already dead person which they have to
steal from the morgue on their way there
Toby reveals to Isla that their mother
committed suicide and will blames his
father for it at the morgue Toby
distracts the keeper allowing will and
Isla to successfully steal a corpse of a
man named Phillips that night will and
Isla sleep on a bunk bed together will
tells her that his mother killed herself
on the day of his parents wedding
anniversary his father was never
attentive and she was left hopeless when
Thomas didn't come out of his office on
their anniversary will had found her
dead body in the bathtub the following
morning the two talk for a while and
sleep while holding hands the next day
everyone is ready to perform the
experiment they attach The Corpse's head
to the device and hit a button while
Thomas waits for something to show on
the monitor nothing happens they do it
repeatedly but to no avail a discipline
pointed Thomas leaves the room and
everyone else follows however when will
is alone inside the monitor starts
working and shows a clip of Phillips
meeting a woman at a hospital will
quickly turns it off before Thomas comes
in again they have to let Phillips's
body go for cremation and Thomas asks
Toby for a new corpse will and Isla take
the corpse back to the morgue and leave
it on the ground outside all of a sudden
Isla kisses will the two are awkward
later and do not talk on the ride home
will cannot get the thought of the video
out of his head he has downloaded it to
his laptop after some research on the
internet he finds the hospital in the
video will drives to the hospital and
walks through the passage Phillips had
walked however he reaches a dead end
that was not in the video a janitor
informs him that there used to be a
passage before the hospital was
renovated a decade ago will realizes
that the video could not have been from
the future he predicts it to be Philip's
memories displaying on the monitor later
everyone gathers at the Mansion for a
session when Thomas calls a patient
named Lacey to the stage Lacey has been
speaking against the discovery and
Thomas's new invention claiming that it
will cause more mass suicides Thomas
confronts her in front of everyone as it
turns out he had found Lacey in the
woods ready to kill herself and had
saved her in the end he asked her to
pack her bag and leave the establishment
will is furious at Thomas for
embarrassing Lacey but Thomas dismisses
the matter later will shows Isla
Phillips's video the two go to the same
hospital to investigate Phillips's case
together they find Phillips's father's
file with his address on it they believe
that in the video Phillips was visiting
his father on his deathbed and the woman
he met was probably a relative later
that night will has a chat with Toby who
tells him that Thomas has been working
on this machine for their mother Thomas
is guilt-ridden because of his wife's
death and wants to know she went to a
better place the following day will and
Isla go to the beach where Isla tells
him that her five-year-old son had died
by Drowning at a beach because she fell
asleep that was the reason she wanted to
die before will saved her the two then
go to Phillips's house and meet his
sister who happens to be the woman from
the video she informs them that Phillips
never came to meet her father at the
hospital none of his family likes him as
he had been awful to them will has
noticed a tattoo of a lighthouse on
Phillips's arm in the video but the
woman tells him that he had a wave
tattoo instead will realizes the video
is not Philip's memory but rather his
afterlife Phillips has gone back in time
to correct his mistakes in life after
his death as it turns out in the
afterlife people relive an alternate
version of their life and get a second
chance to make different choices will
and Isla are surprised by the discovery
they are in their room when suddenly
Toby barges in and calls them to see
Thomas Thomas has attached himself to
the device to try to figure out the
machine he has suffocated himself and is
on the verge of death the monitor starts
working again this time it shows Thomas
on the night of his wife's death it was
their anniversary he had not come out of
his office that day but in the video he
tells his wife that work can wait and
has dinner with her he had been given a
chance to correct his mistake and he did
right after watching the video they
unplugged the machine and bring Thomas
Back to Life by electrocuting him with a
defibrillator Thomas is shocked and
delighted to see his device work it
turns out that when a person dies he
goes back to a time in his life that he
regrets the most and gets a second
chance to make different choices he
gathers everyone in the house in the
front yard and is about to tell them
about the invention when suddenly a
gunshot is heard Lacey who has been
kicked out of the Mansion has shot Isla
she claims that she didn't kill her just
gave her a new beginning before being
taken away by Toby Isla falls to the
ground and tells will that she doesn't
want to die anymore will is devastated
when she takes her last breath in his
arms sometime later we see Toby and
Thomas talk about Isla's family for a
police report Thomas decides to destroy
the machine after seeing the impact it
has on people but when Thomas tries
going inside his lab he discovers that
is locked from the inside will locks
himself in and attaches himself to the
device he suffocates himself and when he
is on the verge of death Will finds
himself in a memory of himself back on
the ferry will meets Isla again and asks
her what is going on Isla reveals that
this is a memory because will is
connected to the machine and is not dead
Isla here is his own subconscious in the
memory Isla reveals that he has been
living this part in Loops in multiple
lives the two first met on the same
Ferry many lives ago but in that
scenario will didn't see Isla trying to
commit suicide and couldn't save her
when he read about her death the
following day he was filled with guilt
because he knows he could have done
something on the ferry he went on living
his life but the guilt always remained
with him eventually when he died he was
brought back to the ferry where he met
Isla again because he regretted this
moment the most in his life however will
couldn't save her even then in a similar
way will has been stuck in this Loop and
lived his life hundreds of times trying
to save Isla but he'd never been
successful until his most recent life
will has met her numerous times so a
part of his Consciousness remembers her
that is why Isla looked familiar to him
when they first met Isla tells him that
since he has been able to stop Isla from
committing suicide in this life he has
made peace with his Consciousness and
has no regrets now also because of that
he would now end up somewhere else in
his next life and not on the ferry will
promises that in his next life he will
remember Isla just then he begins to
hear the voices of Thomas and Toby they
are trying to jump start his heart but
their attempt is unsuccessful and Will
dies after he dies his afterlife takes
him back to a beach will sees a little
boy is alone playing in the water he
takes him out making sure the kid
doesn't drown just then Isla comes
running to them and we see that the kid
is Isla's son will now has been sent to
save him Isla thanks him and walks away
with her son neither of them recognize
the other as will walks away he turns
around with a confused look on his face
suggesting that he is starting to to
remember Isla the movie ends but we can
imagine that will perhaps asks Isla out
for coffee or something like that
afterwards
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching